hey Ozzie what's your son's name Jack
hey Jack how you doing hi nice to see
you how cool is it having Ozzy as a dad
very cool yeah right yeah you seem like
a good kid you know what I mean well he
looks like a little angel I can't
believe he's Ozzie's kid but do kids do
the other kids like Sam can listen to
him you're right Sam kedison walk in
dude do the other kids expect you to be
wild because you know your father's
supposed to be so wild at this school I
went to an L.A they expected I'd come
into school in a helicopter right they
thought you would be a wild kind of guy
like your dad Ozzy
bite the head off a bat do you hear
about that story dad supposedly bit the
head off a bat um second day at school
is kick him with me
and what'd you say
yeah he did yeah you better not mess
with me
if my dad'll bite your head off of you
my daughter Kelly comes out she goes
Daddy they hate me at school I said tell
him your dad's a nutcase
I do but they don't give a [ __ ]
but your dad uh your it is cool the
other kids must go oh can you can you
get me uh Ozzy's autograph and all this
kind of thing yeah yeah well your father
has accomplished greatness and you
realize that right yeah yeah so it's
good to have a genius for a father right
now do you listen to your dad's music
I have to he forces you too huh Jack you
ever seen your father on stage
loads of time isn't that great that's
something how all those kids worshiping
him and stuff that's gotta really oh my
God what that's all about don't you and
when your father comes home what do you
think I mean am I good how could you
even get angry with him or or uh or or
challenge him in any way he's Aussie
right he's Ozzy he's normal dad you do
think he's a normal dad do you realize
that other people have your father's
name tattooed on them
[Music]
Malibu and said oh I had your um you
signed my um arm and I had it tattooed
on yeah that's crazy isn't it yeah yeah
that is wild that is wild well everyone
loves Ozzy I love Ozzy look at you at
the corner did they look at you at the
corner
it's him are you sitting in the doctor's
officer saying these two are women we're
looking at them like this
[ __ ]
you should have told him that's Ozzy
you gotta tell people
that sneeze oh um I got the Slime and it
was green then put it on his nose dad
put that on his nose just walked out
into the hallway and goes we've got a
tissue and this woman freaked she's
running around she's trying to get an
issue it's later she walks in goes here
you go does that embarrass you when he
takes green slime and lets it hang out
of his nose like a snot you tell him to
do it you're like having a good time
he's sort of like a friend a pal yeah
yeah it's great wow and then he um put
slime in his mouth acted up
what a party it must be you know this is
a pretty good sitcom because Jack is so
mature and everything yeah and he's 11
years old and Ozzy acts like a baby all
day I think Jack is with his dad today
to watch his father
dad's out mooning a priest and Jack's
like dad put your pants up
thank you